avait pas par la petite elizabeth est
heureuse de revoir sa mère elle vit chez
sa grand-tante c'est elle qui l'élève il
isabelle il ya tout juste d'avoir 50
les images de son sauvetage avaient fait
le tour du monde au moment du séisme
elle venait à peine de naître mais elle
avait réussi à survivre
huit jours seul sous les décombres de sa
maison de jacques noël orsat septembre
c'est ça c'est par les hommes c'est un
bon dieu parce que c'était pendant les
hommes est tellement pas ta poésie ni
passé ses visites l'a fait qu'il joue je
fais que quinze jours 12 janvier à faire
quinze jours l'effet 8 juin m'a dit
qu'on a ça sent bon et au bon sens -
réveillère passait simba d'accès avec
badge et au départ à capitol hill
isabelle a eu beaucoup de chance
elle s'en est sorti sans une égratignure
aujourd'hui c'est une enfants plein de
vie
la ville de jacmel elle n'a pas été
épargné les traces sont encore bien
visibles
ces belles maisons coloniales celle
qu'on appelle les maisons importés n'ont
pas résisté
elles sont laissées à l'abandon certains
propriétaires sont à l'étranger
d'autres n'ont pas les moyens de les
faire démolir
l'hôpital aussi avait été largement
endommagé la croix rouge canadienne est
en train d'en construire un nouveau
le bâtiment aura trois étages c'est un
gros projet 15 millions de dollars
des dons recueillis par la croix rouge
canadienne et la croix rouge américaine
ils ont donc que cette cet hôpital et 7
la reconstruction de l'hôpital par la
population canadienne c'est une
opportunité une aubaine pour la ville de
jacmel ce qu'il reste du vieil hôpital
réussit même à fonctionner mais dans des
espaces beaucoup trop petit vous êtes là
vous voyez dans quelles conditions on
est logés là il est au service des
urgences ne serviront pas tout à fait
vous avez oublié but 3 4 5 lés on n'a
même pas une unité de soins intensifs
mais il faudra encore patienter cinq ans
ont passé et les nouveaux locaux ne
seront pas prêts avant le mois d'août
pour la semaine prochaine
on prévoit des mètres de béton
c'est une firme québécoise qui a fait
les plans tout est fait pour respecter
les normes parasismiques et
anticyclonique les plus strictes dans
les contextes comme debaty l'hôpital
sainte justine en entier même si ici on
parle des deux états de transit mais
toute la logistique l'organisation et
l'approvisionnement de matériaux et
les aléas météorologiques la culture du
travail local et pose des défis vraiment
un an
il n'y a pas que l'hôpital
jacmel se relève lentement la promenade
au bord de la mer a été refaite des
ponts vétustes seront bientôt remplacés
des centaines de maisonnettes ont été
donnés mais c'est loin d'être suffisant
pour ce militant qui lutte pour de
meilleurs logements
on est totalement panne de construction
ont baissé à l'humanitaire la preuve en
est que cinq ans après les familles
vivent encore dans les chercheurs c'est
au camp d'hébergement beaudoin que le
maire de jacmel nous avait donné rendez
vous c'est pas la condition de vie d'un
être humain s'était dit c'est à dire je
peux dire totalement et leur doit on
absolument violée en tant qu'être humain
3700 personnes qui vivaient dans des
tentes ont été relogées dans ces
minuscules abri sans eau potable sans
électricité il n'y a pas d'école pas de
place publique pour se retrouver
pourtant ce n'est plus considéré comme
un enfant mais comme un nouveau quartier
de la ville alors toutes les
organisations humanitaires sont partis
le maire blâme la communauté
internationale et il rejette toute part
de responsabilité c'est malheureux c'est
ma lui et j'étais pâmé à l'époque
maintenant je suis maire depuis depuis
novembre 2013
maintenant je suis en train de
travailler avec le comité du camp
pendant toute la visite avec nous le
maire était accompagné de représentants
des résidents mais aussi d'un policier
c'est que la colère gronde aussi de
baudouin c'est le même affaire on est
comme ça le regarde chaque jour nous a
proposé hier aux fermiers n'a fait quand
ils viennent nous regardent comme ça et
voilà je suis jeté ma soeur du tueur et
à l'ifsn l'emploi pneus nous vivons seul
ça seulement deux jeux comme c'est
souvent le cas le problème le plus
criant c'est le manque de latrines
elles ne sont plus entretenues la
plupart sont bouchées il n'y en a que
deux sections rappelle mes enfants ont
été contaminés par ce qu'il n'y ait pas
à ces toilettes publiques dans le camp
les latrines déborde
quand ils arrivent ils mettent leurs
mets partout ensuite et de les mettre
dans leur bouche
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
été contaminés claude marie mozac 28 ans
à la cinq jeunes enfants dont quatre ont
eu le choléra elle a eu à peine assez
d'argent pour payer leurs médicaments
heureusement il vaut mieux aujourd'hui
elle gagne sa vie en cassant des pierres
qui servent à la construction de maisons
son mari aussi un travail exténuant dix
heures par jour pour 250 gourdes c6 de
la reynie avec leurs enfants avec leurs
proches
ils sont 18 à vivre dans cette minuscule
maison
en plus il loue une partie de l'espace à
une autre famille pour se faire un peu
d'argent
j'ai passé 50 misère depuis notre
arrivée ici personne ne vient nous voir
c'est nous-mêmes qui faisons de notre
mieux pour survivre il n'y a aucune
occasion à saisir
alain baud avait dit tout ça c'est pas
une maison c'est un cachot le mot créole
koons cette cachot ça c'est pas une
z'ont mais ce camp n'est pas le seul
projet mal conçu ces maisonnettes
construites par caritas sont plus grande
mais elles n'ont pas non plus d'eau
potable
le nouveau centre de convention a été
doté d'une immense génératrice pour
éclairer tout le bord de mer
mais le ministère du tourisme n'a pas
les moyens d'acheter de l'essence pour
la faire fonctionner et même à l'hôpital
on s'inquiète pour la suite des choses
une fois le projet terminé
ça m'a pas le plus de décès a aussi un
rôle important à jouer en ce sens là le
rôle d'accompagnement à jouer on ne va
pas miser seulement sur la coopération
canadienne sur ce que les canadiens
accordent donc il ya un problème de
gestion énormément donc il faut toujours
penser à ça faut voir c'est à dire c'est
comme si vous offrez une voiture de
formule 1 à quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
de rouler un taco de 1945
ça va pas s'en sortir l'écran de cet
électrocardiogramme par exemple a été
brisée il n'a jamais été réparé l'est
alors que va-t-il se passer avec les
nouveaux équipements
avons nous les moyens de gérer cet
hôpital moderne
nous ne sommes pas à montréal ne sont
pas new york ne sommes pas à paris nous
sommes en haïti où il ya des problèmes
d'eau potable où il ya des problèmes
d'électricité où il ya énormément de
problèmes de gestion dans
l'administration publique
donc si ce projet s'accompagne d'une
aide à la gestion sur le long terme qui
permettent de faire face à tous les
défis que cela va poser pour nos hôtes
haïtien d'avoir même c'est peut-être un
hôpital moyens pour moyens mais pour
nous c'est un grand hôpital moderne est
ce que nous serons à même de pouvoir la
gérer
au delà de l'équipement du béton
beaucoup d'haïtiens se sentent oubliés
dans ce processus de reconstruction
laissés pour compte
ils ont le sentiment que leur sort ne
s'est pas améliorée pardon il faut fait
pas gaffe travail ont levé cette chute a
au moins les vtt action partie va donc
senna l'avais moi même j'avais perdu la
vie est devenue plus dure à jacmel vous
avez un enfant qui est comme une héroïne
un miracle comme ça s'est produit
et vous n'avez même pas les moyens de
l'envoyer à l'école vous comprenez des
fois le découragement m'envahit au sein
des fois qu'on ferme découragé il ya
cinq ans le monde entier s'émouvait
devant tant de dévastation dans un pays
déjà six points devant aussi les
survivants d'une telle catastrophe les
haïtiens avaient l'espoir de voir leur
pays reconstruit en mieux
aujourd'hui beaucoup ont cessé de croire
au miracle